intanto
complimenti a
a chi mi ha preceduto che
non è tanto legato a quello che dirò
intanto massima solidarietà che avete
resistito devo dire svizzeri e svizzeri
quando mi è stato proposto di fare
questa questa esperienza è stato un
sacrificio da poco perché siamo in
italia parlo per chi non è italiano
domenica si vota io faccio il consulente
di politici per le campagne elettorali e
un momento molto bisi quindi è stato un
sacrificio che però affrontato venire
qua volentieri per la sfida importante
perché come maria pia sa io sul sud
punto molto e quindi non potevo non
potevo mancare e mettendomi un po in
crisi maria pia mi ha detto vieni qui e
racconta una storia e devo dire mi ha
messo in crisi perché il mio mestiere
per chi non lo sapesse è comunicare cioè
aiutare i soggetti che possono essere
politici industriali istituzioni i
partiti
diciamo vari soggetti eventi culturali
importanti come questo a comunicare ea e
mi fa racconta una storia il mio lavoro
è molto terra terra io uso dire emma è
poco
non si presta a metafora è molto molto
terra terra per cui ho cercato di
mediare con le esigenze narrative di
questa giornata è anche l'idea che
venendo fin qua volevo essere in qualche
modo anche a utile a chi ci ascolta
per vincere questa sfida perché è
importante che matera all evento che si
che ci sarà qui sia una sfida vinta
cioè
la comunicazione non è un terreno su cui
si può sperimentare non si può giocare
perché sul sul percepito e a milano ne
sappiamo qualcosa con l'expo si vince o
si perde si può vincere o si perde per
una sfida quindi vengo qui non tanto con
l'intento di raccontare una storia ma
umilmente nel darvi qualche così
amichevole consiglio su come dal mio
punto di vista approcciare una cosa così
importante
intanto la prima cosa che mi viene in
mente e viviamo nell'epoca della della
narrazione dove adesso si dice l'epoca
della narrazione
in realtà chi di noi ha fatto tutti noi
le abbiamo fatte un minimo di studi
classici eccetera
sappiamo che la narrazione è sempre
esistita facciamo qui non c'è la slide
per motivi tecnici ed è colpa mia non
degli organizzatori la moneta
dell'impero romano che raccontava in un
modo o nell'altro l'imperatore era già
una narrazione c'erano gli storici tipo
svetonio tu lo sai che di giorno
raccontavano in un modo l'imperatore e
di notte di raccontavano le orge e le
cose che facevano anche quella era
narrazione sono tutte cose diciamo cose
che il consenso la comunicazione
diciamo espressione di una ricerca del
consenso è da sempre stata una
narrazione la bibbia una forma sublime
di narrazione quindi in realtà niente di
nuovo sotto il sole
quello che però importante qui vengo
alla storia
[Musica]
posso anche legarmi all'urina scusate ma
posso legarmi all'urina così ecco
l'animale cosa fa quando soprattutto
l'animale che vuole imporsi l'animale
che vuole maschile o femminile che sia
perché non è questione di animali ma che
vuole determinare il suo potere
chiamiamola così la sua immagine sul
territorio italy notoriamente ma non
solo i cani usano la mediazione
dell'urina lo dico perché mi ricollega a
quanto ho sentito prima hanno fatto
appunto di tipicamente studiato con
ralph lauren se c'è scritto sopra dei
libri e quindi marcano il territorio per
la comunicazione non è molto diverso
cioè è importante per qualsiasi soggetto
comunichi che macchi subito da subito il
proprio territorio tradotto che
significa noi tutti viviamo di percepito
solo che il percepito nostro non lo
determiniamo noi il il la nostra
reputazione non è determinata solo dal
nostro lavoro sarebbe bello no che noi
fossimo di identificabili in quello che
ci dice nostra mamma per esempio che
siamo i più bravi a persone non avviene
perché la reputazione e la sintesi dei
valori che sono espressioni si del tuo
lavoro ma anche degli altri di quello
che dicono gli altri
tant'è che oggi adesso una piccola
digressione con l'ingresso del web nei
canali di comunicazione molto massiccio
abbiamo assistito dei casi in cui la
reputazione veniva completamente
distrutta da meccanismi e inseriti nel
web magari completamente scollati dalla
realtà quindi suicidi quindi violenze
questo per citare un caso estremo dove
si può diciamola
il gioco della reputazione o addirittura
se diventa una palla nel campo dei
propri avversari portare alla
distruzione e alla morte però cerchiamo
di essere positivi allora matera
affronta una sfida importante una sfida
che a mio avviso deve vincere sul piano
dei contenuti e ci sono i contenuti ci
sono ci sono i contenuti della città ci
sono i contenuti culturali c'è
l'entusiasmo c'è la voglia di fare
squadra tutte qualità che secondo mia
secondo me possono portare a un successo
però ci sono delle incognite che intanto
diciamo diciamoci la verità è stata una
grande vittoria ma il sud è il fanalino
di coda dell'agenda politica che che se
ne dica è il nostro sud
diciamo anche proprio nell'approccio
legislativo che c'è anche ne parlavo
l'altra sera in alcuni provvedimenti che
si fanno anche sulle pensioni c'è gente
che deve avere la pensione di 35 anni ma
chi minimamente conosce il sud ma chi ha
35 anni di contingente anche proprio
l'approccio dello stato nel fare le
leggi del legislatore secondo me non
tiene conto di quello che succede qua
c'è tant'è che a volte mi domando dove
vivono sti qua te che noi abbiamo una
parte del paese che è oscurata
completamente dall agenda politico
istituzionale e quindi con questo voi
dovete fare i conti è vero che ci sarà
l'anno prossimo un importante campagna
elettorale per cui però la campagna
elettorale che sarà va a coincidere con
una fase sempre più calda di
quest'evento rischia di oscurare può
essere anche un'opportunità
sta a voi tutto questo per dire che
imporsi in comunicazione è come vincere
una campagna elettorale
in fondo tutti cerchiamo consenso in
fondo tutti cerchiamo di far passare i
nostri messaggi anche qui siamo qui sul
palco per dire la nostra e per cercare
di raccogliere il consenso su quello che
abbiamo detto personalmente sono molto
franco molto sincero dico le cose come
stanno
dal punto il mio di vista tecnico e non
mi piace illudere però alla fine alla
nostra funzione è anche questa anche
stare su facebook nella forma di ricerca
di obiettivamente di consenso quindi
matera deve vincere la sua campagna tra
virgolette elettorale nella sua e il
prodotto è l'offerta culturale offerta
che ci sarà però per fare questo ci sono
delle regole base
intanto il posizionamento cioè come si
vince in comunicazione se si riesce a
definirsi rispetto al proprio
competitore se il tuo competitore chi
definisce cioè dice all'opinione
pubblica come sei tu hai già perso
quindi su questo punto matera si gioca
una scommessa molto importante tradotto
cosa deve succedere
bisogna capire il termine brevi quali
sono sintetici i valori con cui si
identifica questo grande evento di fare
un momento di sintesi e partire dall in
questo è il primo diciamo consiglio che
vi do perché faccio un esempio così ci
capiamo tutti
la svolta dell'expo è arrivata quando ha
scelto un percorso chiaro discutibile il
cibo che però ha avuto un grandissimo
pregio ha preso il consenso di un paese
che sul cibo fonda la propria identità
sociale culturale territoriale quindi a
si è posizionata in un campo fece finché
l'expo non si sapeva bene che cosa fosse
tra gli scandali la ndrangheta
dagli appalti truccati eccetera nel
momento in cui sono riusciti a
identificare a dargli un'impronta l'expo
ha iniziato a essere identificata essere
qui è molto più complesso perché abbiamo
un contenuto culturale alto però la
sfida è importante è che sono e secondo
me è percorribile
dovete vendere a mio avviso un
attraverso matera la possibilità che
questa parte del paese scusate se
insisto su questo ma io la sento molto
ce la può fare cioè come ce l'ha fatta
nella candidatura ce la può anche fare
nella sua realizzazione nella sua
articolazione io ho molto apprezzato
anche la stamattina oggi nel corso della
giornata il dialogo anche con soggetti
di altri paesi
la collega dall'albania eccetera perché
questa è la strada cioè collocare matera
all'interno di un universo del
mediterraneo con il quale vuole
dialogare per caratterizza l'evento e
questa è la seconda domanda a chi deve
parlare quest'evento a chi agli italiani
agli stranieri acqua cioè identificare a
chi si vuole parlare perché presumo non
abbiate energie economiche sconfinate no
penso che saranno circoscritte
la gente qui deve venire deve essere
attratta deve essere portata e non
avrete gli ar milioni di euro per fare
campagne pubblicitarie presumono lo so
non ho studiato bene 26 ma lo escludo
quei pochi soldi che ci saranno vanno
mirati bene perché la gente deve venire
qua e fare questa esperienza e quindi
diciamo così sapere bene a chi si vuole
parlare è il primo passo e poi come
farlo e che strumenti utilizzare
minazione web media stampa locale stampa
internazionale e tutti gli ingredienti
che ci voglia in questo caso specifico
da quello che ho visto eccetera il
prodotto c'è molte volte il prodotto
è un prodotto di marketing cioè viene
costruito in base a logiche legittime di
marketing che però vanno messi insieme
vanno vano qui c'è perché c'è un
territorio straordinario giusta
l'intuizione di valorizzare che anche
qui si percepiva oggi le realtà locali
perché anche la stessa candidatura
unesco la riconoscimento unesco che c'è
stato quando sono andato a leggere
motivazioni è stato proprio quello c'è
stata una candidatura credibile perché
veniva dal territorio e secondo me
questo corso va va seguito va
consolidato nel tenendo quindi diciamo
incontra territoriale forte e l'afflato
internazionale però tenendo conto che
siamo nel mediterraneo non si può
ammirare ovunque bisogna ammirare a
delle realtà diciamo che abbiano un
senso
tralascio il discorso sulle
infrastrutture perché ci porterebbe
lontano e tutto sommato devo dire la
città è più raggiungibile di altre
realtà del mezzogiorno però osservando
ma quello che ha fatto marsiglia che
venuta prima no di matera
diciamo che marsiglia si è molto
positiva del massive messaggio che ha
dato è vero siamo la città della mafia
del porto del quello o quell'altro che
l'altro ma questa è l'occasione che noi
vogliamo sfruttare per sintetizzo per
ripulirci queste fare un museo che non
avevano mai fatto
in vent'anni un museo che un misto di
arte contemporanea cose varie eccetera
quindi di trasformarci da un po città
della mala a un soggetto culturale
multietnico e multirazziale perché
marsiglia è a me piace tantissimo come
città è un misto cioè cultura islamica
cultura ebraica fortissime un bellissimo
e sinagoga marsiglia italiani eccetera
e però a marsiglia ha dato ha dato un
messaggio chiaro cioè questa deve essere
un'opportunità culturale
anche all'infrastrutture quindi il porto
che grazie all'evento è stato
completamente rimodernato e
ristrutturato quindi non sottovalutare
anche questo aspetto che non compete a
chi comunica ovviamente compete a ai
politici compete alle istituzioni ma
rende credibile anche l'offerta di una
città cultura siamo in italia capitale
della cultura
mi capisci cioè siamo tutti d'accordo
sulla cultura che la cultura è un valore
del leitmotiv ma in questa storia di
materia che vorremmo raccontare di
matera secondo me bisogna io dicevo
nella slide non appesantire troppo la
parola cultura cioè questa deve essere
un'opportunità anche secondo me che i
giovani vengano qua e che purtroppo noi
purtroppo è la realtà generazioni
giovani comunque che si sono formati in
un certo modo ormai digitalizzate
eccetera porsi come cultura bene ma
trovare le forme i linguaggi le cose gli
eventi e vedo che qualcosa è stato fatto
di importante già è un percorso di
narrazione importante cioè io credo che
la magia di questa di questa realtà
possa veramente fare a trasmettere una
sensazione del nostro sud nuova cioè un
sud particolare diverso anche dagli
altri in cui note o anche un
atteggiamento si dice l'ospitalità si
dice che è una caratteristica del nostro
sud però traduciamo queste cose in una
leva anche di per far venire la gente
per farlo scoprire farlo conoscere ai
giovani anche perché la sfida è quella
il futuro è quello cioè se noi vogliamo
rilanciare il sud
dobbiamo passare attraverso questa
questa cosa se no non ne usciamo dal
punto di vista meramente operativo
suggerisco che ci sia una diciamo un
luogo più o meno pensate
tante strategico chiamiamola kabi non mi
piace cabina di regia però per vincere
la famosa storia della campagna
elettorale all animale che fa la pipì
per delimitare il proprio territorio
comunque non ci possono essere otto
teste c'è il re leone che pensa per
tutti quindi questo è molto importante
una struttura che pensi e che poi
declini va bene la parcellizzazione
degli eventi anzi è irrinunciabile
perché questa è una realtà territoriale
importante che va fatta vederti non si
possono fare solo tra virgolette i sassi
c'è tutto il territorio da varie cose da
far vedere è però le azioni devono
partire da una struttura che pensa e che
dice poi come si deve vincere come ci si
deve rapportare nel lanciare il
messaggio la messaggio di cultura passa
attraverso gli eventi che verranno fatti
ma anche attraverso io li chiamo
testimonial cioè persone che secondo me
voi potrete coinvolgere non
difficilmente che in qualche modo
parlano alle persone che volete far
venire qua
lei ne è un esempio cioè se io voglio
parlare ha infatti è stata giusta
l'intuizione di coinvolgerla
dimmiquando finito il tempo perché poi
ok io vado avanti e va benissimo per un
certo tipo di mondo anzi è stata e poi
utilizzare dei testimonial che ognuno
può essere un modo per convincere le
persone a venire a parlare delle menti a
pubblicizzati e guardate siccome questa
è una terra con cui a cui tutti teniamo
è molto più semplice coinvolgerli di
quanto si pensi quindi è importante
arrivare ai propri obiettivi
anche attraverso persone che li
raccontino è che arrivino ai destinatari
che vi interessano in base alla classe
l'età e il tipo di media che consumano
perché no qualcuno del mondo dello sport
che può coinvolgere rendere meno diciamo
spaventevoli il termine cultura e quindi
aprirsi in questo senso va dalla
chiusura fondamentale e e questo già
qualcosa è stato fatto e qui chiudo il
coinvolgimento in questa narrazione
avete bisogno di alleati siete nella
giungla e dove l'offerta ci sarà tanta
offerta ci sarà tante proposte ci
saranno tante distrazioni e in questa
giungla avete bisogno di alleati lo
stato potrà darvi una mano fino a un
certo punto però fondamentale qualcosa è
già stato fatto di importante il
rapporto col privato con le con le
aziende con le imprese io credo che il
rapporto con l'impresa sia un rapporto
che può determinare il successo di
questa operazione perché qui si possono
offrire location si possano offrire
situazioni interessanti per l'inglese si
possono offrire contaminazioni
importanti personaggi che possono
attrarre sponsor e quindi da questo
punto di vista secondo me ci vuole un
pensiero ad hoc
chiudo dicendo che questa è un'occasione
in lo ripeto importante per il nostro
sud cioè è importante che questa cosa
arrivi nel modo giusto è una delle poche
occasioni di riscatto che abbiamo in
questa parte d'italia e in un momento in
cui c'è un processo di emigrazione molto
forte no da qualche anno quindi non si
sperimenta piuttosto fermatevi un attimo
riflettete sulle percorsi da fare
non fidatevi troppo dei politici perché
la politica è però responsabilizzate lì
perché anche dal successo e li qui la
leva su cui potete fare leva parlando
con le istituzioni dal successo di
matera passa anche il successo del
consenso della politica
quindi la politica e deve essere un
naturale alleato come l'impresa ma verrà
di stata come già distratta dalle sue
dalle sue mille problematiche però è
sufficientemente intelligente da capire
che se questa cosa va bene va bene anche
per le istituzioni è un po cinico mi
rendo conto quello che sto dicendo da
però è un mondo che conosco bene conosco
bene i meccanismi come funzionano e non
possiamo permetterci di perdere questa
occasione quindi in bocca al lupo
[Applauso]